let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 starting today with our caller from
the 2:1 for area code who's calling
today from 2 1 4 hey Dave yeah I can
what's going on now we're not on speaker
are we alright what's on your mind
yeah it's ok ok thanks for taking my
call
well a few weeks ago a few weeks ago
you're asked an audience question about
whether the economy does better under
Democrats or Republicans right and you
mentioned stuff you've mentioned several
metric stock market GDP unemployment but
there's a note of metric you didn't
mention which is recessions I was born
in 1958 and there have been 11
recessions in my lifetime one of them
started when Jimmy Carter was president
the other Ken all started during
Republican administrations only one
Republican in my lifetime to remember
I'm 62 years old
mainly one republican in my lifetime
Gerald Ford who served less than two and
a half years didn't have a recession
start while he was president however
thanks to his Republican predecessor
Richard Nixon
we were already in a recession and when
he took office you under 40 so every
Republican in your lifetime has had a
number of recessions equal to the number
of terms they served
I mean they totally can't go for years
without causing a recession
seriously how do they maintain this
reputation for being better on the
account are they just better at brandy I
think so I mean yes that so it's all
linked to the simplicity of a lot of
these ideas sort of like hey I mean you
know taxes are your money and you should
keep it and it must be better for the
economy if people keep the money they
earn so we're good with the economy
right it's like simple it's ideas that
are that simple that take hold I just
don't know how the American people can
be that easily fooled it's just crazy
well we know they can because Trump is
president valid point man that's why I
was wondering my friend thank you very
much love your show all right
from Dallas Dave from Dallas on fire
shot out of a cannon there and getting
right into his point I love it
let's go next to our caller from the
nine five four area code who's calling
today from 954 hello yeah who's this hi
this is Alma Justin from George I'm
calling from La Johns Creek Georgia hey
Justin hi I love your show um I had to
kind of to two questions so to speak the
first the first concerning let's say
best-case scenario happens in November
we get when Joe Biden Joe Biden defeat
Donald Trump resoundingly we expand our
job we democrats expand a majority in
the house and take back the Senate yeah
what are there any potential guardrails
or anything we can do to uh like prevent
prevent prevent Ron bender under and
McConnell and the Republicans from just
going go going off the rails burning
everything down and the Indy six week in
the ten weeks ten or eleven weeks
between Election Day and when I didn't
is inaugurated well assuming you're not
literally meaning starting to burn
things down they can only really do so
much I mean Trump will probably if let's
not put the cart before the horse but if
it gets to that point and Trump has that
two and a half month lame-duck period I
think mostly Trump would recede into a
shell and blame everybody other than
himself for losing if that happens and
might not try to do that much but the
things he would likely do would include
pardoning people executive orders that
he believes would either be digs at
Obama or Biden or ways to get favors to
his friends but I I actually don't think
that you know the real concern would be
do they try to push more judges through
and that is something that maybe
Democrats would be able to prevent on
the same basis that Mitch McConnell
prevented Merrick garland from getting
to the Supreme Court I think if Trump
loses he's going to be so distraught he
won't be doing very much during that
lame-duck period
I think I showed my help so I mean we
finally we know that he's basically I
mean my hope is that the worst he does
is sense of nasty son to petty tweets
about how it was rigged or how he was
how he was treated unfairly but it just
sort of that empty threats yeah I mean
the problem about the tweets about the
the problem of tweets about the election
being rigged is that as stupid as those
would be they likely would inspire some
of his followers to potentially become
violent and that's something that is
potentially potentially very problematic
listen Justin I know you had a second
question I'm gonna let you go because
your your connection is is not great and
we want to make sure that we can hear
everybody beautifully so I will have a
lot of people holding I do want to get
to